the entire city of new orleans is
without
power following the arrival of hurricane
ida to the u.s gulf coast the category 4
storm brought powerful winds after
making landfall in the state of
louisiana damaging power lines as it
moved inland forecasters say the storm
could bring a potentially catastrophic
tidal surge and major flooding in its
wake
it's not just the harsh winds as
hurricane ida plows into louisiana the
storm brought torrential rain and a
tidal search to the gulf coast
thousands of residents followed an
evacuation order issued before ida's
arrival
those who stayed behind have been told
to shelter in place
ida maintained its intensity even after
hitting land
government officials said the storm
would push the people of louisiana to
their limits there is no doubt that the
coming days and weeks are going to be
extremely
difficult for our state
and many many people
are going to be tested in ways that we
can only imagine today
but i can also tell you that as a state
we've never been more prepared
the slower a hurricane moves the more
rain falls in the same place and ida is
in no rush to continue its journey
inland
with the storm moving slowly the rain is
flooding cities and the wind has cut
power to hundreds of thousands of homes
but officials are ready to move in as
soon as the storm weakens
we've already pre-positioned resources
that we know are going to be needed
and equipment and response teams in the
region
this includes 2.5 million meals
3 million liters of water
we've got generators in place and we're
in close touch with the power providers
to get and restore power as soon as
possible
emergency officials say it will take
time before they can assess the damage
but parts of louisiana may be
uninhabitable for weeks or even months
ndw correspondent oliver sallett is in
the region that's bearing the brunt of
hurricane ida he sent us this update
this is what meteorologists have called
the strongest hurricane to hit louisiana
in 160 years and hurricane ida battered
the city of new orleans with winds of up
to 150 miles per hour and officials
urged residents who did not evacuate to
remain sheltered in place calling this a
potentially life-threatening storm and
now those who sheltered in place who
stayed at home are facing other problems
because nearly the whole city of new
orleans is effectively without power
it's a giant power outage that affects
more than one million people here in the
area and in addition to that we have
seen collapsed houses the fire
department reported of people trapped
inside
roofs that were blown away the whole
louisiana coastline experiencing a
catastrophic storm surge followed by a
tornado watch and all of this is
happening 16 years after hurricane
katrina killed 1 800 people just here in
new orleans
and of course the impressions we're
getting are dramatic and in spite of
that city officials expressed confidence
in the flood protection system that
underwent a 14 billion us dollar upgrade
after hurricane katrina and of course
now all hopes are that the levees will
hold this time around
and for the very latest now i'm joined
by matthew capucci he's a meteorologist
for the washington post thanks for being
with us matthew how strong is this storm
well the good news this was a smaller
storm in terms of size than hurricane
katrina but that said it was more feisty
in terms of the wind winds gusting
upwards of about 250 kilometers per hour
make it the eighth strongest storm to
ever hit the united states in terms of
the continental us a remarkably potent
system one of the big issues now though
even though the winds have subsided a
little bit heavy rainfall being bringing
huge problems in the new orleans metro
area with upwards of 25 centimeters
having fallen on the big easy itself now
the levees you mentioned earlier on
they're holding back the sea water but
they're trapping the rain water and
because the entire city is without power
they can't really pump that water out so
it's a flash flood emergency for that
city
talk to us about the storm's path
matthew who's most at risk
new orleans was very lucky because the
storm passed only about 45 kilometers
off to the west had that eye well come a
little closer to the city instead of
winds gusting to about 140 they might
have doubled that so we were very
fortunate there right now tracking a
little bit to the west but eventually
we'll curve through mississippi and up
to the tennessee valley and ultimately
the mid-atlantic region later on this
week the threat shifts from damaging
winds to more of heavy rainfall possible
flooding and isolated tornadoes we saw
that tornado watch in effect the
louisiana metro area ultimately a couple
little spin ups are possible thanks to
all the rotational energy associated
with that system ultimately it has to go
somewhere and so hurricanes tend to spin
down into smaller storms capable of
producing tornadoes
now all of this is happening of course
16 years to the day after hurricane
katrina devastated new orleans more than
a thousand people were killed there is
it clear that
that kind of destruction can be avoided
this time matthew
i think back in 2005 after hurricane
katrina the city officials did a good
job they invested about 16 billion
dollars worth of money into
infrastructure trying to make sure the
levees would hold and this time they did
now that said katrina was simply a
different beast about 20 hours before
its landfall in 2005 it was a category 5
storm and it was so big that it pushed
way more water ashore this storm ida
really intensified at the last minute
kind of got its act together as it was
moving ashore so it didn't have as much
time to push that water ashore and had a
smaller footprint so while the surge was
less significant probably about three
four meters still very formidable we
just didn't really have that test that
katrina would have given if it occurred
again so we're very fortunate this time
around that it wasn't worse but that
said considering the winds considering
the rainfall it's a serious impact i
think new orleans will be cleaning up
for quite some time
matthews thank you so much that was
meteorologist matthew capucci
you